NARRATOR: Deep beneath the
surface of the Zambezi River
in Zimbabwe, Africa,
Kristen Yaldor
is trapped in the jaws
of a hippopotamus.
As she struggles
to free herself,
the animal refuses to let go,
rag-dolling her back and forth.
Hippos wouldn't necessarily
just drag their victims
underwater like a crocodile.
They're not predatory species.
They actually just eat grass.
So when Kristen got
dragged underwater,
it's likely that the hippo
was actually just returning
to where it's comfortable,
underwater, where it knew
that it had the
advantage to make sure
that it eliminated
any threat that it
felt from Kristen's canoe.
I was almost out of air, and
I started to re-swallow my air,
knowing that might help me
conserve my air in staying calm
and allowing me to try to
survive in this moment,
because I didn't know how
long this was going to last.
The hippo can hold its breath
for two, three, five minutes.
Kristen, being shook around,
probably doesn't have much
more than 30 seconds of air.
And so he's likely going
to last longer than she is.
I had to try something.
I grabbed its mouth to try to
pry it open and didn't budge.
I'm not strong
enough to do that.
I instinctively then just curled
up to try to conserve my breath
and not be thrown around
so much underwater.
And somehow, it let me go.
DR. CAMILLE FRITSCH:
It's possible
that when Kristin grabbed
on to the hippo's snout,
it actually got spooked and
let go of her, because there's
very few animals that a hippo
would have bit onto that would
have had the same reaction.
And it's possible that
actually saved her life.
Kristen!
So what seemed like
forever, I'm standing
there screaming in a panic.
And all of a sudden, Kristen
does pop to the surface.
I immediately saw Ryan
running on the shoreline
with a terrified
look in his face.
I immediately started to paddle
towards Ryan and the guides,
but I couldn't swim.
My leg wouldn't work.
I screamed for help and
somehow I instinctively
turned over and backstroked.
Drifting downriver on her
back, stroking with her arms,
trying to push herself.
So at this point, I'm like,
could this hippo come back?
Is there a crocodile up river?
Was whatever I needed to do
to get over there to help
the guides get her
out of the river
so that the water
just didn't carry her
continually towards the falls.
You know, that's where
this river is going is,
is over the Victoria Falls.
As she passes us,
there's nobody around.
I couldn't hear anything.
I was just focused on myself
trying to get to shore.
And then I heard the guide say,
reach for the canoe paddle.
[sobbing]
NARRATOR: Ryan and a
guide pull Kristen ashore,
where they get a clear
look at the massive damage
the hippo did to her leg.
When I look down, I could
see that my leg was torn open.
My skin was ripped off
of my leg and is laying
on the side of my leg, and I
could see part of my muscle
that was torn off sitting
on top of my thigh.
Hippos have these incredible
weapons in their mouths,
where they have these
two canine tusks
the size of a flexed human arm.
But they don't actually
use them to eat.
What they use the teeth for
is to defend their territories
and to attack other
territorial males.
Kristen, at this
point, is repeating--
I need help
before I bleed out.
I knew I had limited time
if I was bleeding out.
So my panic and my
instructions to the guides
were I needed help
immediately, otherwise
I was going to die here.